nobody diving though everybody's
standing around the corner
and there it is
the kid from akron lebron james has come
into the nation's capital and has passed
the mailman karl malone and is now
number two all time in scoring in the
history of the nba
foul call here as we get another look at
lebron moving into second place
with his uh last basket
nice dive i was just talking about how
nobody's moving and lebron said hey
don't worry about it i'll dive
dives in gets the easy deuce and that
puts him all alone at number two
crowd just being
made aware of it they're giving him a
standing ovation justifiably so
former teammate
kcp
won a championship together
[Applause]
i'm sure it'll be a humbling moment for
lebron
now kareem abdul-jabbar the only one in
front of the king who'll go to the bench
and he'll be going back to cleveland
next game what a moment for lebron james
number two all-time scoring in the
history of the league
as he exits though now it's up to the
lakers to generate some